the q7 t is infinities flagship sedan
infiniti is the top range arm of
Japanese automakers Nissa the q7 t first
went on sale in germany in 2010 with its
economical 4-cylinder diesel engine this
sedan has got its sights set on the
German business class so how does the
Japanese premium sedan perform we're
going to find out car tester on the Left
stack says the Infiniti q70 is great for
long distances the double-glazing
greatly reduces exterior noise the 2.2
liter diesel engine is quiet - except
when the engine is still cold Ronnie
says that for the first few kilometers
you hear a deep humming noise but it's
not dramatic our test car has a 2.2
liter diesel engine this is the bottom
of the range engine for 4 cylinders
previously the q70 was only available
with a v6 diesel engine the common-rail
four-cylinder engine is considerably
more economical and harmonizes well with
the standard automatic transmission
though the transmission doesn't always
manage to change gears smoothly Ronnie
says that under the hood the Infiniti
q70 is a real money saver that's down to
the fact that this 2.2 liter diesel
engine is made by Daimler it was
incorporated into his vehicle especially
for the European market but with the
vehicle weighing around two tons he says
this 125 kilowatt and [ __ ] feels
slightly underpowered the Infiniti q70
excels with its distinct design thanks
to a bigger radiator grille and
redesigned headlights the q70 cuts an
even more imposing figure than before
its roofline resembles a coupe a and at
the back it ends with an overhang over
the trunk overall it has sleek rounded
lines
and the car's interior Infiniti pulls
out all the stops and a bid to live up
to its upscale image it takes a bit of
time to get used to the host of buttons
with tiny inscriptions on the steering
wheel and dashboard fewer switches would
be preferable but the sumptuous bucket
seats and the heated steering wheel are
a real joy
our car tester says he first checks out
the sound system when buying a new car
the Infiniti q70 has a Bose sound system
a good thing in itself is Ronnie but
more unusually the speakers are built
into the seats the result he feels as if
he's in a concert hall thanks to the
partnership with Daimler and the related
downsizing this diesel model of the q70
can now be bought for eight thousand
euros less than its predecessor in
Germany the sedans list price is
forty-four thousand five hundred euros
that's about how much you pay for the
basic version of the Mercedes e-class
which has an identical engine but you'll
get more fixtures and fittings with the
Infiniti many features that you usually
have to pay extra for like LED and
adaptive headlights come as standard
you